toutes les communautés quelles qu'elles
soient
et de pouvoir raconter leur histoire
nous faisons partie d'un regroupement de
cinéaste noir ayant pour mission
d'apporter une nouvelle façon de
représenter nos communautés et ainsi
enrichir la culture et le cinéma
québécois est mondiale
[Musique]
nous voulons bien sûr l'appui de notre
industrie afin de pouvoir partager le
film
non réalité nos émotions avec un public
en manque de représentation raconter nos
histoires faire prier nos stars décider
des thèmes que nous voulons aborder et
décider de l'image que nous vouloir
projetée dans l'univers médiatique
tant qu' on laisse à d'autres personnes
de les regarder comme dans un espèce de
de microscopes et analyser on aura
toujours un regard biaisé qui où les
populations concernées ne se
reconnaîtront pas quand vous regardez
trop ma fonction qui tourne ici dans une
autre dans un hôpital dans la région de
montréal on le voit aucun doctor qui
sont ici des minorités racisées
pratiquement pas de personnel
d'infirmières est issu mais pourtant en
réalité qu'on regarde dans les hôpitaux
dans la région de montréal c'est trois
docteurs sur cinq qui sont ici des
minorités nos culturel donc on va
commencer à ce qu'on se retrouve dans
une zone télévision qui est absolument
pas représentative de la réalité ici au
québec
donc on ne voit plus on est exclu on
pourrait donner des tas d'exemples la
liste absolument avant qu'est ce qui
s'est produit durant le black façon a
dit ben bella blackface existe pas ici
au québec ait jamais eu de bug fils même
si calixa-lavallée pendant 12 ans il
ferait partie d'une troupe ministre elle
en moi quand je regarde les médias qu on
a débattu ce sujet là qu'est ce qu'on
parle de qui parle dans les médias
c'était des blancs avec des blancs qui
parle de sujets nous voulons changer le
courrier sud en développant un cinéma
afrocentrique
[Musique]
du moment qu'on ait la possibilité de
raconter nos propres histoires et on
demande à des personnes qui n'ont pas
forcément la même sensibilité que nous
de nous financer pourquoi quand on nous
propose histoire d'où l'importance à
moment donné d'avoir effectivement des
scénaristes
des cameramans des réalisateurs des
producteurs issus de ce monde là donc le
jour on arrivera justement à trouver des
des personnes qui soient conscientes
comme non comme on l'a fait comme l'a
fait la musique black qui a réussi à
trouver un public au delà du public
blacks
il a apporté aussi qu'au niveau du
cinéma au niveau de l'image on arrive à
trouver
les moyens et les financiers qui vont
pouvoir s'associer à nous pour pouvoir
rejoindre notre public parce qu'on a
beau faire des meilleurs films du monde
tant qu'on n'a pas le
les infrastructures ce à dire les
canalise diffusion qui vont atteindre
les personnes auxquelles ces films sont
destinés et ben on en restera toujours
dans le même combat qui est comment
faire pour financer nos films quoi
[Musique]
il ya que blick et là il ya public est
là et qui se reconnaît pas et le suivi
de ce public de plus en plus nombreux et
se reconnaît pas forcément dans ce qui
se passe à la télévision ce qui se passe
au cinéma
donnons le micro et donnons les caméras
aux personnes
qu'ils vivent leur histoire et puis
laissons-les ne raconter et je pense
qu'ils ont plus de chance dans ce cas là
deux touchés
le basque en deux ans dont on tait juste
important que que que nos enfants
puissent un moment donné regarder la
télévision et puis se reconnaît dans la
télévision allait au cinéma sur le
connaître au cinéma et a été d'être des
caricatures voir des spécimens je pense
que c'est quelque chose d'important qui
contribue à l'éducation de masse